[Musique]
et
je m'appelle thomas
ça fait plus de 40 ans que j'habite à
fond et je vais vous présenter la
coutume mauritanien quand on a un invité
qui vient chez nous il y amène à lui
donner le lait on a deux sortes de l'est
aussi est allée des cahiers de démarrage
[Musique]
aucun mot l'italienne ou ou par du thé
vert
et on chauffe de l'eau yahoo lyonnais et
on fait trois verres
il était chez nous ça prend beaucoup de
temps pas besoin en effet la mousse avec
les verts mattel fait parce qu'à
l'époque
les gens habiter
dans le sable donc ça permettait en fait
de filtrer les faits à la pression vous
voyez c'est comme ça
et ça c'est le beurre de en général ces
deux blocs de chefs ou des chats des
vaches
avec la date
[Musique]
et après on va commencer à miami le
pâtre traditionnellement italien ça
c'est la lui laisser assez de couscous
le couscous on le fait avec les nuits où
le cac dans le rouge et il nous fait une
sorte de famille et la femme en façade
le nez dans le grand amphi qu'elle fait
l'écho et où il avait dans le couscous
hier pendant presque deux fois trois
fois et a prénommé une sorte de coup de
chez nous qui s'appelle cap y met un peu
de temps et là où il fait la force
commune le dessus
[Musique]
adan
adam
[Musique]
quels étaient les liens